okay I think we can get started No
session so looks like there are more
Android developers in this conference
than iOS developers how many of you will
here actually attend at my mind yellow
session my Android session so so okay so
I can reuse my jokes so okay so my name
is Wei Ming so I'm here to talk to you
about react native how to use react
native to develop iOS applications so
how many of you here are actually Xcode
developers okay one how about the rest
okay since this this is a small crowd I
think we can make this more interactive
so what is the mean and afore coming for
this session are you a web developer
windows developer and you want to learn
how to develop iPhone apps yes okay cool
you have come to the right place and
you'll believe whatever I say okay so so
if you're new to to iOS development let
me just give you a very quick
introduction so if you want to develop
native iPhone applications you can use
the tool provided by Apple which is
Xcode and you use the language either
objective-c which is a really really
painful language or you can use the new
Wall Street for gaming language so but
the problem here is that a lot of people
not only wants to develop their apps for
the iPhone platform they want their apps
to be able to run on Android devices as
well
so people are looking for a
cross-platform solution so so if you are
a developer faced with this kind of
requirements it's always good to find a
solution a platform that allows you to
write once run everywhere so react
native allows you to do that pretty
easily so and that's the agenda for the
next 60 minutes I'm doing going to try
to convince you to tell you that react
native is the best tool to write your
iPhone apps so my agenda is very
straightforward I wanna get you started
with react native and I will try to
convince you why you should use the
react native and I will talk about this
two features called live reload and hot
reload and I will show you how to
perform common tasks with react native
things like location-based services
to display maps how to create
applications navigation applications how
to persist your data using databases so
and so forth and I will show you some
really cool things called life updates
using code push now what is reactive so
I am pretty sure most of you here are
familiar with react for for the web so
react native is actually based on react
as well it's a JavaScript framework for
writing native ios and android
application notice that i focus on the
word native native meaning it is not
running behind a web browser it is a
pure first-class application first-class
citizen on your iPhone devices and as
such it doesn't have the usual
performance problems of hybrid
applications like you you heard from
your friends who are using things like
Cordova I own a myself off so it's based
on react and you write react native apps
using a mixture of the following
JavaScript ok so how many of you are new
to JavaScript ok good I think everybody
is from from Illamasqua right so you
guys love JavaScript CSS I I don't think
I need to introduce to you what CSS
right so and then gsx so JSX is
basically a combination of JavaScript
plus xml also known as i'll put it this
way in the past we call this spaghetti
code but but this is really cool ok so
so your react native basically
translates your UI mock-up to native UI
elements and hence your app is a pure
native app now why use react native so
this is the I think to a lot of
developers this is the most important
thing convince myself convince my boss
to allow me to use react native you can
use it to write cross-platform apps so
for those of you who have actually
downloaded the NDP application onto your
iPhone
Android devices III basically basically
wrote that application using react
native and 99% of the code is actually
running on both platforms so in fact
just for one bit particularly the rest
of the code is is basically write once
run on two platforms so I don't have to
really spend too much time trying to
customize my app to look different on on
each platform apart from one very simple
component so your apps retain the native
look and feel of each platform so if you
were to download the app you run on
iPhone it looks just like an iPhone app
if you download this on an Android
device it looks just like an Android
application so it's pure native it's not
hybrid and it allows you to really
efficiently test your app so when you
want to make changes to your app once
you have deploy your app to your
emulator to your real device you mix
changes to your JavaScript code you save
your code the changes would
automatically be reflected on the
simulator or on the device itself
there's no need for you to redeploy your
application onto your device game which
is all usually a time consuming affair
so you can use this feature called live
and hot reloading to instantly see the
changes we are caught now I will show
you a demo and then it has got a very
good community support so the nice
things about react native is that it's
open source so if you need help you can
get help on the on the web stack
overflow has got tons of discussion on
this and if you need a certain feature
in your app and it's not available in
recognition to go to Google you search
for that there is a package out there
that can serve your requirements so
whatever you need there's a package out
there and as the same goes there's a
package for that okay so whatever you
want somebody has required that some
time back so you can also do a code push
meaning after you have developed your
app you deployed this to onto your App
Store and for those of you who have
actually deployed on develop on Xcode
before you know what you know
the nightmare right you deploy all your
apps on the App Store and then Apple it
takes how long does Apple need to four
to forty eight hours yes and it is
pretty accurate now this is like
typically you deploy today tomorrow
morning when you wake up it's it's
approved okay and for those of you who
actually deploy applications before you
know that's the happiest moment in your
life when you're at least approved do
you agree
just don't tell your wife okay don't
don't have a wife that that's the
happiest moment in your life in so if
you're I've you know why ask you say oh
no the getting married to you is the
happiest moment in my life okay so so
you think could push what you can do is
that the moment your app is a proof on
the app store the user is running your
app what you can do is that you can make
changes to your code send it to this
server by hosted by Microsoft code push
and your your your users would be able
to use your app and dynamically check
for updates against the push server and
then download the updated UI and then
run the updated application on your on
your iPhone and so this is something
that is really really cool but as far as
the app store is concerned there's
something there is of a gray area
because depending on depending on how
much what did you change if you say that
this is a sports application and after
your update this becomes an adult
application this is not going to be okay
okay so it's a little bit grayish here
so you gotta be careful
but for adding minor bug fixes minor UI
updates I think that's perfectly fine so
react native is available as a no js'
package so all you need to do is install
node.js on your machine npm and then
install the CRI and install this tool
known as watch band which will
continually monitor the changes in your
code inner files and then update your
applique
when you make changes so the best way to
see how this look is to create an
application okay so let me just delete
this guy and let me show you how to okay
so let's whoops try to create a new
project a react native project so react
native in it
hello NDC and then you can always
specify the version that you want to use
the the the good news of react native is
that at this moment it's not even in
version 1.0 it's not even in 1.0 who can
tell me where's the latest version of
react native way I guess forty seven
point one zero point four seven point
one so why is this good news your
potential employer can never can now no
longer ask you do you have ten years
looking experience with react native
okay when that's the real world right
they will always say we need a developer
with ten years booking experience with
c-sharp so now I got some questions
later special of my my native so I'm
going to fall back on point for for so
but a B so I am creating a new project
so let me just create that so what
happens here is that it is now creating
a project so my project is here
so it is going to create the project
create a node modules that I need for my
project and once this is on let me open
up the project and let me show it to you
okay so almost done okay now so this is
the components all the files that we
have in our project so let me just run
through that very quickly so I have a
few folders a few files so the folder
that is named Android it's the source
code for your Android studio project so
if you are testing this on a Android
device simply use Android studio open up
the Android folder and that is your
Android project the iOS project which is
what we want to focus now is in here so
if I double click on this it will open
up my Xcode okay and this is basically
an Xcode project now the good news is
that you don't really have to get your
hands dirty with Swee for objective-c
interfaces objective-c
all you need to worry about is this -
for this file index dot IO SJS so this
is your your your main page so double
click on that let's take a look now as
you can see this is JavaScript
now before we run through this let me
just run my Xcode project deploy this on
to my simulator so just put this one
site
and my simulator is up and running there
you go hang on
no I think I'm gonna close this guy fish
today over let me just close this
project they go I run and running the
wrong project so let me just run this
okay
okay so let me run through this so
basically what I have here is that I
have a react native project I have a
component call
hello NDC and I have a render function
so this render function basically
renders your UI and if you look at this
this is your very familiar HTML like
kind of mock-up so this whole block
itself is called JSX javascript
extension so it's a mixture of XML and
you can actually embed JavaScript code
within this block of code and so this is
called JSX so what hackney happens
behind the scene is that react native
would launch something called a package
manager which is running behind the
scene here it basically converts your
JSX
into es5 JavaScript and this JavaScript
is then it is then sent over to your
iPhone application and it will render
the UI like a native application so if
you look at this part here and you
compare this with what you see on the
simulator
welcome to ranked native welcome to
react native and so I so forth
now what about making changes so I want
to make some changes to this and I say
welcome to NDC I can save this and
usually in Xcode if you want to update
your app after you have made changes you
what do we do you go back to Xcode you
redeploy right so on the iPhone davonne
react native you don't have to do that
you all you need to do is come on our
it's updated so my app is now updated
and on a real device all you need to do
is
shaking your device and then we'll bring
up this def menu and you do a reload and
it will reload automatically so there's
no need to redeploy and this feature
itself saves you a lot of time when you
when they are testing your application
and this is called live reload now I can
automate this process I can do this I
can do a enable live reload so if I
enable this all I need to do is I go
back here and say welcome to my session
and I do a save and it is automatically
refreshed are you are you impressed no
okay nevermind okay go back to Xcode
[Laughter]
okay so this is a react native let's
continue so so this is the the these are
the steps to run your application so you
open on your open your iOS project in
the iOS folder using Xcode and then you
select the iPhone simulator or your real
iPhone and I run the project and the
packaging manager which runs behind the
scene would automatically launch and it
would serve and it will compile your day
exact cool and then send it over to your
iPhone application so this is my
hollower now to enable reloading you can
do a command R on the simulator you can
do a reload and for real devices you
basically just shake it now so this is
how reality works
so it basically acts as a bridge between
your your javascript code and your iOS
platform so it basically converts your
application from JavaScript into the
JavaScript that the native application
will be able to understand so that the
application will be able to build a UI
or
the platform itself natively now at this
moment react native only supports iOS
and Android so what about the other
types of platforms
what other platforms are important what
are the platforms are available today
for those of you who are mobile
developers right
besides iPhone besides and right what
are the other mobile platforms that are
forget about Windows Phone Tizen Tizen I
think you can forget about typing as
well
tell me honestly which are the devices
running Tizen the Samsung gear 3 right
that watches ok
and who are we how many of you are
wearing Samsung watches anybody take it
out give me back to me I think in India
there are certain models they are
running
Samsung has got certain models in India
they're running Tizen but I think in
terms of worldwide adoption I think so
far it's not really successful maybe
they will but as a developer I I I don't
think that that's a formidable platform
I think for the primary reason a
developers are simply to tie it
developers have enough of iOS and
Android if you give them one more
platform you're the kuelen okay so what
else Windows Phone I think unfortunately
Windows Phone is almost dead still
breathing but you know waiting for the
final day nail
but somebody see anybody say blackberry
[Laughter]
so now recently some companies actually
talk to Facebook about using react
native for the platforms I think
Microsoft is one of them but not for
Windows Phone I think for their Windows
platform
no no for winners for and then the other
company is Samsung I believe Samsung for
the TV setting that TVs okay now so
react native actually gives us this
promise write once run everywhere right
and I'm sure as a developer you're very
familiar with this you heard this in
1995 okay write once run everywhere
right but in reality is right once debug
everywhere so so you remember this guy
that shows how oh you are this Java
right is the the Java Duke and this guy
keeps on spinning and then when they
launch when I first launch Java they had
this this thing called Java applets and
then the first demo that they created
was this guy jumping on the webpage can
you recall that I was finishing my
studies during those days and then we
first saw this we were so excited we
don't even know what Java so we took
some simple code when modifying and me
and my few friends they say let's start
the company let's try to sell this java
technology even though we don't know
what the hell is it so let's try to sell
this to businesses so when we talk to
businesses we say hey we are now able to
make sure your webpage can bounce so so
we are too excited but then we don't
really know what to do with it so so in
the end we we didn't really create
anything and that's why I'm here today
so this is JSX so JSX is basically a
this is a better representation of GSX
so it's basically xml plus a little bit
of if you look at this javascript code
so when i first encountered JSX my first
impression of this was this looks like a
SP active server pages right you know
in the asp 1.0 2.0 days we have a name
for this speck at decode right so so
it's like Oh everything comes back one
big round so so you can combine your UI
markup with JavaScript but you don't
have to do this in react native if you
do not want this if you do not want to
use JSX but using this will make your
life much much easier ok so if you do
not want to use JSX this is how it looks
like you can write all the code for the
UI elements you have to create an
element yourself manually but but yo
depends sometimes developer certain
developers got very high threshold for
pain
they like coding you know so now react
packager so the real package basically
converts the source code of your app so
it does the following it transpires your
code from JSX to Angmar script it
converts your code from egg man script
2016 also known as es7 and egg man
script 2015 also known as es6 to es5 so
this is the package manager in action
when you run your application this is
the package manager so it runs behind
the scene and it basically it's
basically a web server application and
it basically serves the quote the
compiled code at this URL and so if you
were to use a browser you click on this
punch in this link you'll be able to see
one whole bunch of JavaScript files no
JavaScript classes so this is your react
akka Jerr
now for those of you who have done Xcode
Apple introduced this particular feature
called or Tulio
what of this if you are Xcode developer
there's no reason why you do not know
Auto layout it's a pain in the back do
you agree those of you who have done
Auto layout so it makes your life really
really difficult
why because you guys want to have big
size large screen sizes so Apple work in
order to make customers happy they have
iPhones of different sizes but then in
the end in the end who suffers developer
suffer because developers must do extra
work
I remember life was really really
peaceful until iPhone 5 from the first
iPhone to iPhone 4s life was really
peaceful because when you do your UI is
either retina or non retina display
that's it one point translates to 2
pixels starting from iPhone 5 you got a
lot of nightmares now so react native
doesn't use auto layout
it doesn't use constraint layout in
android it uses something called flexbox
and i think if you are a web developer
flex boxes pretty straightforward and I
mention if you think of Auto layout you
have typically this kind of reaction and
you know who is this guy right and I
know you guys love him now so to allow
you to do your layout flexbox offers the
following three main properties a flex
direction justify content on line items
so let me just quickly go through the
basics of Xbox so if you look at this I
have a view so in this case it
represents the entire page and we need
this video I have a child of which is
another view and
this first view has got the style
container so you apply the following
attributes justify content Center
Alliance item Center and I have a child
which has got with 80 high 80 and the
color is blue now so in your head can
you try to visualize how does it look
like how does it look like so I got a
pitch
I got a square in the middle right do
you get it right okay now so this is
easy what about this so now I have added
in two more views so what is it gonna
look right now before I tell you the
answer now by default items in a
container arranged vertically in column
format by default so it looks like this
now okay so this very much web base
looks very much like a web application
now how about if I change the direction
to role so remember the default is
always column if I change this to row
it's going to look like this I can
change the sizing so I can specify a
Flex attribute so I can have a flex one
flex one flex one so in this case now we
don't me showing you this the look and
the definer look can you can you try to
imagine how it's going to look like do
you get this right so flex one basically
means I want to occupy as much space as
I possibly can so but in this case you
got three views here within the same
container it's just just like you buy a
cake back home if you are the only child
you can have the whole cake right and
that's what I say you can have our cake
and eat it too so but if you have a
sister's or you have sisters or brothers
then you have to share
equally among them right so in this case
because they are Tresor you were split
evenly so so this is the explanation but
B specify flex : 1 each view would have
with the other available space but
because they are 3 so they will be
divided equally and in this case even
though I specify my wave to be 80 but I
have flex it will overwrite the
attribute called whiffed next one I
specify my Flex direction to be column
and I specify Flex one for each of the
views so you will look like this ok I
can specify maximum width so I can
specify that in this particular first
view the maximum wave is 90 so in this
case it will stop at 90 maximum and
because the rest have got flex 1 so you
will they will divide the remaining
space equally among the second and third
view ok what about flex 1 2 3 so in this
case I am specifying the ratio so so 1
is to 2 is to 3 so if we run this I'll
get something like like this okay so
quite easy to understand just a fine
content if I were to specify flex 1 flex
Direction column justify content equal
to flex start so can you can you imagine
how it's going to look right now what
does flex that mean so but this time
right is column okay so column so the 3
views would be aligned in a column
fashion and flex that means a line to
the top start with the top so it will
look like what I have here okay so
you need to take note of the following
you have a flex wand for this view
continue the three squares so that you
can occupy the entire column and then
the justified content attribute
basically indicates how its children
should be justified so in this case flex
that means you align to the top and if
you specify that the Flex Direction is
set to a column then justify column
affects the vertical alignment okay so
just ignore this flex and you have flex
start you have flex end so flex end will
look like this but line to the bottom
space a row if I have the Flex direction
you go to column and then I do
especially justify content space around
then I would have equal amount of spaces
for each view or I can have space
between and in this case they would have
to equal space for each view okay the
next important concept you need to
understand is state and props now rather
than go through the items here I think
it's easier to show using an an example
so let me just close up this application
and load another demo so let me just
close up the sky and company at the sky
and let's go to the spinner example
eyewear and let me open up the sky and
I'm gonna run this
okay so this is my application so my
application has called one button so
when I click on the button the label on
this button would change and you will
speed you'll see a activity indicator
spinning here so I click on this guy you
see the activity indicator spinning and
then if I click on this button it will
stop okay now this is a very useful
example to look at state and props so
let's take a look at this very simple
code here now first of all I need to
import all my relevant more juice so in
this case I have a spinner my activity
indicator so I have to import this
touchable opacity is basically to allow
you to have a some sort of like button
so that when you tap it changes color so
this under touchable opacity and I have
a component call my button and basically
my button has got a single render
function this render function basically
draws the UI so my my pattern basically
draws a view and inside this view it has
got a text it has got a label now what
text is my button going to display it is
going to display this dot props dot
label so when I create my my button I
don't know what I want to display so
I'll leave it as this dot props label so
this stop props dot label is like your
properties of your class
so when later on I use my my button I
want to specify the label I will specify
this through an attribute or pass it in
and this is where I get my
my properties and that's why they call
this props now a very good way to look
at this is is this look at this my
button even go down to this page here
you'll see my button here and I specify
label equal to something and so this
label is actually this dot props dot
label so now you understand why I say
props now in my spinner class I have a
constructor and I create the following
what we call States states are basically
variables but states are really powerful
because when you buy your state with
your UI the moment the value of your
state changes your you I would get
automatically updated so that's the real
power of reactive so I create two states
here animating button label so I create
my state animating to be false button
label to be animate so now so this is
how it works I have an activity in any
indicator this is the spinner and it is
whether it is initially spinning it is
determined by this dot state dot
animating because I said to force so
when I first build my application the
spinner is not spinning so it's it's not
visible and my button has got this label
so button label is called animating so
the first time we're on you see
something like this now when I click on
my button when I click on my button I go
to this animate method so this animate
method is here so I check if my current
text for my button my mind my label for
my but
is animate our change it to stop
animating else I will change it back to
animate so once I'm done with this I do
a sent state so I want to change the
state the value of the state variables
that I have so what the moment I do a
set state it will automatically trigger
a render and react native would know
which are the elements that needs
updating and it does so in a very
efficient manner so and this is what
happened so when I click on this guy it
spins and then when I'm done it stops
and so to me this is the main hurdle for
people who are coming in from the Xcode
background when you come over to react
native you just have to get used to the
the new paradigm of thinking the new way
of updating your UI in if you are
familiar with Xcode you are familiar
with IB outlets and you use outlets you
update your state you use IB action you
trigger an action but once you get past
that stage everything is pretty
straightforward
and so you understand what is States and
state and props so I don't have to go
through this okay so this is simple now
so now that we have covered the basics
for a lot of developers who are coming
into a new platform especially for
myself when I when I might try to learn
react me here for the first time I
always tell myself okay I'm able to do
the following things in Xcode tell me
how can I do the exact same thing in
reality and because I have a series of
courses on iPhone development using
Swift and Xcode so I have a set of
materials written using Swift and I and
I sent myself this challenge okay I want
to convert everything that I have into
react native and see how easy it is to
do that so for the next couple of slides
I'm going to tell you what are they what
are the various ways to accomplish the
common tasks
you will usually encounter when you
write a mobile application so I'll talk
about it's not the API is available and
if the API are not available natively
how do you actually get the packages on
the Internet
okay so this list shows the native
components in react native and you have
things like activity indicator yeah
button blah blah blah
so all those that has got a suffix of
iOS it's only available for iOS all
those for Android is only available for
Android all those that does not have the
iOS and Android suffix are
cross-platform because I'm running out
of time so I want to skip through some
things and show you the really
interesting stuff so the first thing
that developers always ask that I want
to be able to display a list of items so
if you are familiar with Xcode you would
no doubt be familiar with table view UI
tableview okay now in in in in react
native you use this thing cross section
list section list is useful if you need
to display your list items break them
down into sections and then you want to
display haters
so the NDC app that I have is created
using section list but if your
requirements is much simpler you don't
need to break them down into sections
you can use what we call flat list so
the same application under the speaker's
tab
it's just created using a flat list so a
flat list is much more easier to
implement and it's also much more
efficient now if you're not getting
locations you can use the geolocation
API and you just need to add your
required the required permissions to
your Xcode project or your Android
projects and then it will allow you to
actually get your locations your
latitude longitude so this is one
example now just my information if you
want my slide you just if you can't just
send me an email and I'll email you the
slice so you have to worry about the
code here even I display maps so this
took me quite a while to do to find a
correct solution
so the
the best way to display maps in a react
native application that's cross-platform
is use the component from air B&B so you
look for react native maps so it's the
cross-platform solution and it
automatically uses Apple Maps for iOS
and it uses Google Maps for your Android
applications and for and Google for
Android applications you have to apply
for the Google Maps API key just in all
of that and typically this is us these
are the steps to install a third-party
component your CD into a project name in
the project folder and you install using
NPM whatever modules you want to use
link that with your project so that the
required libraries are added into your
iOS project your Xcode project as far as
your Android studio project so it works
for most of the components that you find
on the web so this is pretty useful to
take note so this is how it looks like
data storage you can make use of the
async storage so the equivalent of this
in Xcode is your user defaults user
defaults so pasting storage is pretty
efficient so if you have a lot of key
value pairs that you want to save you
don't have to worry about opening up
files databases and so forth use async
storage but if you want to store
structured data you can use a sequel
Lite and there is a package out there
react native sequel light storage that
allows you to store all your data in
secret like databases networking if your
app doesn't have networking features
then it's basically quite a useless app
so every app needs to talk to the
outside wall so you can use the fetch
API supported natively in react native
and it returns a promise object is
asynchronous or if you want you can use
the xmlhttprequest API or you can use
WebSockets
there are also third-party more juice
available socket IO is one of them where
you can actually use socket IO sockets
to actually connect to your back-end
server
navigation a lot of times people need to
do write applications that has got tap
pages navigation applications so I so
forth so for for navigation applications
you can use the react navigation so this
is the recommended frame book to use so
I have one very simple example here so I
have three tap pages and for the second
tap I can click on this button and you
would navigate to the next page and then
I can click on the back button you will
go back to the previous page so okay so
for this one let me just show you a demo
let me show you a demo so that you can
see how it looks okay so I okay
close this guy okay and then let me run
this
okay so it's
okay so I have three tab pages and for
the second tab page I can click on this
button it will go to the next page you
will navigate the next page and then I
can click on the back to go back to my
previous page so you can use react
navigation so I'm gonna skip through
this this part here and I'll show you
something that is pretty cool that it's
called dynamic updates using code push
so basically what do you do here is that
you register your application with could
push so code push is a cloud service
that enables Cordova and react native
developers to deploy apps updates to
their users devices after they have been
deployed to the App Store or Google Play
so so this is what happens so you deploy
your apps to your users devices and then
once the users are running your
application you this is you a delicious
the reason why I use a picture of a
ninja is because you are trying to
bypass Apple and Google okay I should
change this to a politically more
correct picture so anyway so you make
changes to your code and then you push
it up to code push and then the your
application could actually be programmed
to automatically check against code push
for a newer version or you could have a
button in your app to say click on on
this button to check for updates okay so
let me try to show you a demo okay let
me just close off my current project
and okay so my aunt is called mine
dynamic app I've already registered my
my application it's called push I have
to all the keys necessary and then I can
now deploy this application so iOS and
let me deploy this onto my simulator
after this session they say there's a
party hearing okay so let me finish this
before you get drunk okay
so is this running okay okay just bear
me for five minutes if you can yeah he
just couldn't wait okay okay so so this
is my application running from my
package manager here all right so if I
were to do a refresh wait okay wait hang
on
the reason is because I I have already
selected my scheme to be released okay
that's good okay now let me actually to
you if I said this to debunk the scheme
to be debunked by default let me just
open up my project again sorry if I by
default when you create and reject
native application you deploy this onto
your iPhone or iPhone simulator by
default the scheme is always Dibby Dibby
basically means when you run the
application is going to load from your
package manager okay and how do you
actually verify this no I think it's let
me just okay let me just close this guy
okay and then that should will again
okay
daga now how do you verify if you look
at the green bar up there it means that
this application is loading the the
application from from your package
manager and then if you do a command R
you are able to refresh directly from a
package manager but so this is useful
when you are when the device is actually
connected to your Mac but then a lot of
times you want to deploy your
application onto your device this kind
of device and go off for tests so in
this case if you do not want to load
from the package manager all you need to
do is go back to your Xcode project go
to product go to scheme edit scheme and
change that to released so when you
switch type the release they are not a
load that dynamically what they're going
to do is that they are going to package
everything deploy that onto your iPhone
or iPhone simulator and then you can
disconnect and go out for your test so
it's gonna take a little bit more time
to compile so let me just run this once
and in the meantime we want to go in
here and look at my index the iOS dot
J's project and I want to change some UI
okay let me just run to finish running
this and then so it's clearer okay
okay okay so my application has got the
following text welcome to react native
iOS uu so I'm going to go in here and
let's just imagine that this app has
been deployed on the App Store it's now
running on a user's phone and you
realize that ah you should have you
shouldn't have this text here because
you copy everything from Stateville flow
without modifying your UI so you go back
change this safe and how do you actually
push that to your user so you do this
there's a command here which let me just
copy this and I'm just gonna run this
and my app
push it so what I'm gonna do now is that
I'm actually pushing my updated code to
push so that later on my user can
actually go to his application click on
this button check for updates and he
will be able to actually see the the
updated app so so my app is now running
okay so it's pushing this okay done so
if the user were to click on this guy he
should see a dialog so there's an update
would you want to like - would you like
to destroy it so install there you go so
the app is it's now updated are you
impressed okay now we can go and get
drunk okay okay so so you just need to
download this component called Rio
native code push and in your you know in
a code you can have a button and if the
user clicks on this button you basically
call this block of code to check for
updates and then you can you can update
you can also do additional things like
you can roll back your updates you can
roll back to a previous version roll
back to the previous end versions if you
want to so check the don't commit doc
you mention for could push now I only
left with four minutes but okay so I
think a few slices and then we're done
now if you are using react native to to
write platform-specific code or rather
cross-platform code there are certain
things that you can use to detect for
specific platforms so you can use the
platform module to know which version of
OS your user is currently on so you can
know that using platform oh s or rather
this is the the os name this is the
version name with Android iPhone weather
10.3 or whatever version you have you
can also use that in your style sheet so
you check if my platform is OS is equal
to iOS my font size set to 20 else set
to 50
I can also do that this way I can say
that platform don't select if my
platform is iOS I wonder we have this
item called background color yellow if
this is Android background color blue
okay last but not least something fun so
I'm not sure they have wait a minute
I've heard of this thing called gifted
chat so give the Chinese a is a module
that allows you to build your chant UI
so the history behind this NDC
application that I have created is this
M was previously created for another
conference deaf teacher in Canada so
when I was building that application I
wanted to incorporate something fun so I
taught that people who are using my app
would one to have a way to check
real-time with fellow attendees so
imagine you've got 50 of you in in a
session and you want to talk to your
fellow attendees about the feedback
about this session so you would go in
here and you will be able to chat with
one another so I wanted to build a chat
new i but at the same time I wanted this
to be cross-platform so I was looking
around and I finally stumbled across
this thing called gifted chat and the
check knew I looks very much like your
messenger UI or your message app on your
iPhone and it's really easy to use any
and and copied this with socket IO and a
couple of other modules I'm able to
create a chat application that allows
people to chat real time but I in the
end I didn't incorporate this feature
into the MVC app because I realized
developers don't like to talk to each
other in the death stage conference
nobody wants to use this feature because
they say why should I talk to Miller or
fellow developers so I think they prefer
drinking beer so so so so but I thought
that was a very very cool feature but so
in the end is why
I say okay forget it it's a good feature
but I'm gonna leave it out of the NDC
application maybe I'm wrong but but so
so far this time around I'm not adding
this feature into the app probably
hopefully for the next NDC app I'm going
to add this feature and see see the
response so okay so I think I'm done so
the timing is just perfect questions any
questions before I let you go is there
any angular native not that I know of
know anybody who is familiar with
angular can can can can answer that
question
angular native no no sure
that they say they say there's a utility
running a background called watch man
watch men not to show better you you
remember this light that I show you
earlier on there you go watch man this
is the kind that is constant ring
constantly monitoring the changes in
your inner file system and then if you
make some changes in the file system and
you it will be smart enough to know ok
that involves changes to the app it will
automatically changes back to the
application itself it actually causes
the package manager to recompile the
thing again yeah it does that so so if
you're just trying to try this you go
and make some changes in your in your
code you will look at your package
manager again you realize that they are
reloading that all over again
so that's the magic behind the scene
okay so I I think I shall not how you
bank anymore but if you've got questions
I'll always be around and then I'll be
around tomorrow as well
so thank you very much
[Applause]